okay well thanks very much for inviting
me and for this awesome program
and thank you everybody for sticking it
out to the end of today
a long hard day of lots of algorithms
and cryptanalysis
so yes i will be telling you about how
diffie-hellman fails in practice
so this talk will be much more practical
than uh
some of the rest of today mostly because
we're going to be talking about deployed
crypto
and this is a collaboration done with a
very large number of people
i've had many people ask how did this
happen how could you possibly have
an author list with 15 authors it's
partly because this is about three or
four papers shoved into one
and so that might make it make more
sense and there's like six different
research groups represented here
who do many different things so it's a
long story but i can tell it to you
later if you want um also like this is
kind of a diverse audience and this is
like a little bit further
away from what some of you guys do so if
stuff doesn't make sense just like
ask lots of questions because that's a
lot more entertaining for me so
good okay so i'm gonna go like way back
to i don't know the origin of modern
cryptography this is like the
mathematics of modern cryptography
so maybe this is like the paper that
started modern cryptography i don't know
these people are a lot older now but
hopefully we've
we've all read this and we've all taught
classes where we have like slides like
this
and given papers or given talks where we
have slides like this
i put this here mostly to contrast this
oh now i have a voice
okay i put this here mostly to contrast
sort of alice and bob key exchange with
what you'll see later
so this is like this nice theoretical
version of diffie-hellman key exchange
nice and clear
alice and bob send g to the a g to the b
and
then they have a shared secret and then
they can communicate with each other
looks clean looks clear there's only two
arrows here um
and i will be specializing to
the case where we have a multiplicative
group mod p
in this talk so nothing about elliptic
curves no more exotic groups
just multiplicative groups mod p
so okay and fortunately yesterday
daniella
introduced a lot of this background for
me so i will just
quickly sort of resume some of this just
to get us in the mood
so we have a prime
which is some parameters specified from
on high we'll talk about how where those
come from later
then there's a generator of some
multiplicative group mod that prime
and we know that well um for mods little
theorem okay so the group order
is maybe p minus one maybe something
else
and then we know that the order of the
group will divide whatever p minus one
is
so um and the discrete log problem
which we care about mostly because it
will help us break diffie-hellman in
practice or
dsa digital signature algorithm
is given some value g to the l compute
this log l okay so we have a target
we have a log we try to compute that and
we know that this log
is some value mod the order of g which
is
some value that divides p minus one
so i'm going to just go through the
whole history of discrete log very
quickly in one slide
so the best algorithms for generic
groups run in
time of square root of the order of the
of your group
polar row baby step giant step depending
on how much memory you want to spend
if you have some size range that you
know that your exponent or your
your log value lies in then you can
compute
the log in time square root of that size
range
and if you know the prime factorization
of your group order
then you can compute a discrete log in
each of the
prime subgroups and then use the chinese
remainder theorem to compute
the log in the whole subgroup okay
so daniella talked a lot about this
hopefully you guys have all like taught
this seen this before we're all good
okay so these i mean we we we've known
about these algorithms for
decades centuries uh decades maybe um
but uh so fortunately in practice people
design the parameters so that these
algorithms do not apply
this is not why you're here for this
this talk to see me talk tell you about
like pollard row right um
and so the best practice is that when
you're giving real-life
diffie-hellman parameters uh your
group generator should generate some
large prime order subgroup
modp and so common choices are safe
primes where
p is say two times sum prime plus one
so that you have as large of a subgroup
as possible
or a dsa group which is designed so that
p minus one has some large prime factor
q which is
not say p minus 1 over 2 but it's
something
much smaller say 160 bits or 256 bits or
whatever
that's specified as part of the group
parameters so these are the two
sort of examples to keep in mind in
practice of what these groups look like
or what they should look like so
pop quiz how many people think that
practitioners
deploying cryptography follow the best
practice
who wants to vote yes that's about no
all right right if i'm giving a talk the
you know okay you know what the answer
is
okay um it might be better than you
think
uh so here's some concrete numbers so um
i will talk some more
about https later but um
we scanned the entire internet connect
to every single server say hello do you
speak https
except the encrypted web a little lock
on your browser um
and got back an answer um so of those
uh so there were 14.3 million hosts that
were willing to speak to us
over https and of those 40 24
spoke defeat helmet so
that's reasonable it's actually a much
larger percentage of the websites that
you actually want to talk to support
diffie-hellman
the rest of them support rsa key
exchange if you're wondering
elliptic um helmet and this is only mod
p
diffie-hellman elliptic curve
diffie-hellman
is about 10 or it was the last time i
left
i can give you a reference if you want
the actual number but it's it elliptic
curve is is much lower still
and actually this number is much higher
in the websites that you care about
visiting
mostly because in recent years people
have been saying oh my god everybody
needs to move to forward secret
uh key exchange methods because we're
being spied on by the nsa
so there's actually been an increase in
support for
diffie-hellman an elliptic curve
diffie-hellman key exchange
um so when was this number from what is
this number when did you
get this number this number is from like
april
and you're saying that that's it's
higher now than it was no it's
this is this is the number from april
this number is much higher than it was
in say 2010.
okay so um of these
uh whatever three point something
million
um key exchanges we actually had
seventy thousand distinct primes so
there are a lot of people using
the same prime values which is fine i
mean we don't really have that much
guidance on
how to choose primes as daniella was
pointing out
so there's actually if you look at the
distribution it's like a really long
tail distribution there are a few prime
values that are really really really
common and then there's a long tail of
people who generate their own values
what are those common values the ones
that really use books
the really used ones um the most
commonly used ones
were generated by say apache and openssl
and groups like that and just you know
if you install
some common server software it just will
come with some prime baked in
often there are also a few groups that
were generated
in the 90s they're called the oakley
groups
so there's a 768-bit prime at 10 24-bit
prime
1536-bit prime all the way up to i don't
know 4000 8000 bits
with nice properties like having two as
a generator being a safe prime
having two generate a subgroup of order
p minus one over two
um having the most and the significant
bits be all set to one having
most of the intermediate bits be a
nothing up my sleeve value which is i
think the
binary expansion of pi and
then they increment to you know the next
prime that has all the properties that i
just listed
and these were published in 98
something like that um and people have
been
using them and baking them into
protocols ever since
because i don't know anything about
https so if i'm talking to one of those
servers and he says
here's the here's a prime i i like and i
say i don't like that one let's use this
one then you can't do that
i see the server just says here's here's
my group parameters
so the client has no control over
what's going on depending on the
protocol sometimes the client chooses
their parameters
sometimes the server chooses the
parameters
i have a i have a whole slide that goes
through the the key exchange later on
but i'm doing the math first
okay so the but the uh yeah in this case
the the servers are choosing the primes
and you don't get any input in what they
look like
so the servers that's how many primes we
saw
of those we looked for okay
how many of these are safe primes and
the answer is
most of them actually so there are a few
that are not safe primes
and a priori since we only get a prime
and a generator it's hard to tell the
difference between
a non-safe prime and a like a non-safe
prime with other problems or a dsa group
because we don't we're not given the the
group order to check
so we decided to check whether these
were dsa groups or not or whether there
were additional problems
so we tried to factor p minus 1 over 2
using the elliptic curve method which is
your preferred method if you want to
find small factors of numbers
and of those we learn prime factors of
the order of the
group generator for 750 groups so at
least
750 well so many tens of thousands of
people using these 750 primes
messed up and we're using factors
um we learned some prime factors
not all but but this means that these
are not dsa groups and that these are
not
uh not safe primes so
these people have problems if i say bran
you just mean
that property doesn't mean that safe
means that
p minus one over two is prime yeah so
yeah it's not that
all the other primes shouldn't be used
because they're not safe okay it's it's
fine to use a dsa prime
for a dsa group for example you just
want to be sure that
i mean best practice is you know what
your subgroup is
and it has large prime order
so these people have subgroups that have
composite order that we were able to
factor
just by on a few hundred cores applying
the elliptic curve method for
um several thousand um moduli for like
i think i just pressed go and let it run
for like five days
so were any of those the popular ones
some of them were used by tens of
thousands of hosts
which is moderately but not super
popular
so any of the primes happen to be like
smooth or like d minus one
um so um
okay so it like is this a problem well
it's it certainly breaks
the ddh assumption if we've got a key
exchange of this form but it's not
actually vulnerability
in practice immediately because if
somebody just wasn't paying attention
to the kind of primes that they were
generating and they just generated
some random prime and didn't check if it
was safe for dsa or anything then
p minus 1 is likely to have large prime
factors
and so if we have an exponent that we're
trying to recover well we need to
um if we were going to try to do it with
polly kelman we might have to
solve discrete log over a pr
like mod say something of 300 or 500
bits
which is just not feasible so this is
not like awkward or like a full on break
vulnerability
what's a dsa dsa means um so dsa primes
as specified by the digital signature
algorithm specification
just say that um p minus one should have
a large known
prime order subgroup and g will generate
this prime order subgroup and nothing
else
so these seemingly vulnerable oh g will
generate that subgroup so
you just generate that subgroup that
this could not possibly be a dsa prime
yeah these are these are not
um these guys these 750 are not dsa
or even if the prime minister say g it
doesn't cost you does not generate the
right subgroup yeah
these are people who definitely screwed
up yeah so given that this safe scope
happens for many many connections
like is it because this was embedded in
some software then it got used over and
over again
software
uh we did disclosure to a bunch of
different companies i'm not sure what
the situation is with is that
the prime the final version of the paper
will contain
some example implementations um there
are some devices and there are some like
some cases where we're not sure actually
is one of the
difficulties are these mostly
proprietary or open source libraries
i don't know if we found any uh any
source code
but we didn't look that hard there were
at least 10 different things that did 10
distinct different things that did this
like 10 distinct implementations where
we could tell like these all come from
one implementation these will come from
another implementation
but so they were open source they
weren't
i didn't find any source code but i
didn't look so i don't know
so this is this was a problem more with
the
fact with the order of g then the
factorization of p minus one
he was fine but then they were choosing
a g that
does not have prime out there yeah most
of them just say oh
you know two or five that sounds like a
good generator and
i'm guessing a lot of these people just
said like
i'm going to generate a random prime and
i'm going to take two mod prime
is it enough for g to have the order of
g to have a large prime factor
to get security i'm going to go on to
the next slide and then
um the answer is sometimes yes sometimes
no
so um if you have full size exponents
and you have a large
prime factor of your group order then
you can't recover that full full-size
exponent
but there's a paper of van arshad and
weiner from the
90s which pointed out in theory that
there was this possible attack
if instead of using full-sized diffy
helmet exponents you used
short diffie-hellman exponents so
because exponentiation is relatively
expensive
doing a say 10 24-bit exponentiation
might be more than you're willing to
spend and you say okay well
the best generic attack against um
like exponents within a certain range
for discrete log is
to use polar lambda so we're going to
make
we're going to use say 160 bit exponents
that has secured two to the 80 security
we're totally good
now if you combine this with having
a composite order group that is being
generated by g
then if you can find a set of small
primes
where their product adds up to larger
than your known size of the exponent
then you just need to do the chinese
remainder theorem
for that set of primes and then you
recover the full exponent you don't have
to bother with these
pesky 300 digit primes
you can only focus on the small ones and
then you win so the question that we
asked is did anybody
manage to both combine having short
exponents
and having a composite order group
that they were generating yes
good job so um we ran this for
um just sort of prioritize the the
all of the exchanges that we had in
order of the most effort that we would
have to
use to break them the smallest effort
was like i don't know
30 something bits and then we got up to
40 something bits of security so like 80
um
80-bit primes 8-bit primes and
using that we got 159 full exchanges so
people who actually were using 128 160
bit
exponents and then some people who are
using larger exponents than that
okay this is like a somewhat small
diversion
um so but this is an example of
why applying a small amount of math
knowledge to
the internet is interesting it's a
little bit like shooting fish in a
barrel
i've learned that if you scan the
internet and you look for
implementations that have screwed
something up you will find it
so um and the most interesting reason
that this seemed to happen
actually is um because of a usability
problem with
dsa keys so there are some very commonly
used dsa parameters
people say here's a well-known good dsa
group it's it's specified there's a
here's a prime
here's a group order and here's a
generator and some people
were somehow using the group order as
the generator
which is going to be just some random
number mod p
which is going to generate a random ish
subgroup
mod p minus one so
i thought this was entertaining now
you're all like pumped up for discrete
logs right
so let's move on to more modern
algorithms um so
uh pollard row is is old um
let's talk about some sub-exponential
algorithms so i'm going to explain sort
of
the big picture of how index calculus
works
so okay we're trying to solve a discrete
log
we've heard the word be smooth before so
a number an integer is be smooth if all
of its prime factors are less than some
bound b which is our smoothness bound
um and in the slides that follow there's
just
going to be a magic b that comes out of
the sky so
the sort of general structure of index
calculus looks something like this
this is a little bit different from what
you've seen
but this is i'm trying to build up to
the number field sieve so
you can pretend that like this is the
algebraic side and this is the rational
side
anyway so step number one in index
calculus is we're going
to find a bunch of relations and a
relation is just
a pair of integers that are equal mod p
and that are both b smooth so we are
going to
enumerate integers we're going to try to
factor both of them or write down the
prime factorizations and if the prime
factorizations are
b smooth then we save them and we do
this until we get
enough relations
these are called sieving algorithms
because usually you use some kind of
sieve to actually discover the prime
factorization
so once we have generated a bunch of
relations
well what are we actually doing here i
can write out
each relation here and i've just taken
the log of both sides so i've moved from
a product to
a sum and so i've got some kind of
whatever these exponents are and the
logs of
all of these small primes which i don't
know what the log of
of these small primes mod p is but i
want to solve for it
so now i have a bunch of linear
relations in terms of these logs of
small primes and i also potentially get
some relations for free depending on
what the group is
and once i get so i have say b
unknowns here and i have once i get more
than
b relations then i can solve this system
of linear equations
mod the order of the group that i'm
working over
and then i get the logs of
each of these small primes
in inside of sort of mod mod p
so then i've done all this work i've
computed
the logs of many small primes but i
still don't actually have the log of
the actual target that i was trying to
get so
i'm going to input a target t if my
target if i try to factor it
over the integers if it's already b
smooth then i am done
because then i can just write down the
prime factorization of
um of my target and then i can
write down what the exponents are and i
can substitute in
what the my known logs of each of the
small primes and then i'm done
but if we're not lucky and t is not b
smooth
then we have to do a little bit more
work and
the extra work that you can do is say
try to find some value we just try
random values here
until we find some value say g to the r
times the target that happens to be b
smooth
and if i find a value like that
then i can just write down what the log
of the target is in terms of my known
um well my known value here and the
known
logs of each of each of the small primes
which i have
derived in the previous step so just the
sort of
general structure of this algorithm is
we have a pre-computation which is
relation finding and
linear algebra and then we have the
actual part where we compute the log of
a particular target
so what does the running time look like
the running time of relation collection
depends on a bunch of parameters the
amount of work that it requires
to test if your integer is be smooth the
probability that a random integer of a
particular size is b smooth
and then whatever this value b is
the linear algebra runtime depends on
doing
the cost of doing sparse linear algebra
for some b dimensional matrix mod the
order of your group
and the individual log this depends on
the probability that
somehow you can find some new
modified target that is b smooth so
if you optimize for what the right value
of b is you get a sub exponential
running time so it has this
um l notation so it's
exponential in some constant factor
which here is
square root of two plus little of one
and then it is
um square root of log p log log p
so that's this one have here this is an
l of one half
algorithm i'm going to gloss over sort
of the differences with
the number field sieve mostly the for
our purposes here
there's this extra new step uh in the
beginning which is polynomial selection
so the property that we want is just to
find
some integer m and some polynomial f
such that f
m is zero mod p this will define some
number field that we will be working
over
and then
we have a ring homomorphism between
the ring of integers inside of our
number field and then
z mod pz so then we have
we're going to sort of do the same
relation collection
inside of the number field and then in
over the integers
so here on this side i have my
ring homomorphism i have values a plus b
alpha inside of the number field
if this is a smooth element of the
number field it factors into
small prime ideals and i'm massively
waving my hands here
so somehow you have to believe me that
it's possible to figure out
what smooth prime ideals are you just
you essentially you factor the norms and
you throw in a few other things to
to make sure that you're dealing with
well-formed ideals
um and then here in the integers we're
just factoring relatively small integers
here so i collect a bunch of relations
of this form
then i do a linear algebra step to
solve for the logs of
the small elements in inside of the
number field
and the small elements in the integers
and then
once i've done this step then there's a
last step which is the descent step
which is trying to write
an individual target as the sum of the
logs in our known database
and then if you work through the
parameters here
you get a slightly improved rent time so
now i have massively yeah how much of
this process is shared
between like if you were going to use
the number four the factor
i mean is this is most of the algorithm
the same
it's yeah it's very very very similar so
almost all the code is is the same um so
for discrete
so polynomial selection so for factoring
um
you're trying to you essentially have
the same property that you want except
that for p
instead of p here you have some integer
n um
that's the thing you're trying to factor
relation collection is is very similar
um you have to do a little bit more work
uh to deal with
have making sure your something about
your ideals being well formed
um and then linear algebra the big
difference here
between this in factoring is when you're
doing the number field sift for
factoring your linear algebra is mod 2
and here it's it's mod the order of your
subgroup and then
in the number field sieve for factoring
you don't have a descent phase you have
a
sort of final square root phase at the
end
so this is much more expensive than the
final square root phase
but otherwise this the structure of the
algorithm is very similar and the
expensive parts
the relation collection and linear
algebra are very very similar
so this is sort of a picture of what
the number field sieve looks like um if
you're sort of actually thinking about
implementing it so
here's the runtime that you get it's l
of one third
for the precomputation step with 1.9
as the constant in the exponent and l of
one-third
with a uh a 1.2 constant in the exponent
for the descent
um so this this part only depends on
the prime p prime p actually and this
is the only step that actually depends
on an individual target
and i've tried to draw a little picture
of what steps parallelize well and what
steps don't
so polynomial selections sieving they
parallel they're embarrassingly parallel
you can distribute them as much as you
want it doesn't matter
um linear algebra can be somewhat
parallelized but it's
it's more limited because the the power
the different steps need to communicate
more with each other and then the the
descent is somewhat parallelizable
mostly because you're essentially doing
a lot of resetting
so if you want some practical numbers of
what this looks like
so we let's see this is
uh using the caddo nfs implementation of
the number field sieve
this is done by our collaborators who
are
at indriya and lauria in france so
um for 512-bit factorization here's some
some of the parameters that you would
use this is the sieving range so you
would
save all values a and b up to the 2 to
the i
and then this is the large prime bound
so the size of the prime that you're
willing to
accept beyond the sieving range in to
save a relation
so the amount of core years of sieving
that you would do for a 500
factorization is about half a a core
year
linear algebra is also less than a year
and then there's no
descent so rsa 512
if you parallelize this this can be done
in a few hours
or diffie-hellman uh this we've changed
the parameters a little bit just to deal
with the fact that
linear algebra mod lar your group order
which is a larger number is much more
expensive than linear algebra mod 2.
so because of that that blows up the
size of the linear algebra
so these you can actually do
more sieving and make sieving more
difficult for you by
decreasing the size of your large prime
bounds for example
in order to decrease the size of your
matrix
to compensate for the fact that you have
to do linear you have to do all of your
arithmetic
mod sum q which is larger than two
rather than just mod two
um and then the descent is about ten
minutes
of core time so this is
this gives you some idea of what
concretely it means to have l of one
third with one point nine versus l of
one third with one point two
um and uh on an actual cluster
so the sieving was paralyzed across
uh two to three thousand cores using um
idle time so that's why it varies uh so
this is 15 hours of sieving on
two to three thousand cores the linear
algebra took 120 hours so
several days on 288 cores
and then the descent average time of 90
seconds
paralyzed across 24 cores
so um as far as we know i don't think
anybody had bothered to write down this
is smaller than the current
uh discrete log record which is about
600 bits
but nobody had ever sort of bothered to
write down the case that anybody
actually cares about in practice
for whatever reason questions
good shocked okay
so why do we care about this okay here's
my little picture of
tls this is what the tls
protocol actually looks like so this is
this is a cartoon of the
exchange um so say i want to talk to
each.berkeley.edu i looked around for
like several minutes
simons.berkeley.edu does not speak https
www.berkeley.edu redirect from https to
insecure http so each.berkeley.edu is
willing to speak https to me
so if you are alice and you want to talk
to
um a website secured with https and you
want to speak
diffie-hellman the negotiation looks
something like this so alice
sends over a random value and the list
of cipher suites that she's willing to
support
so hello i'm willing to speak rsa key
exchange diffie-hellman key exchange
elliptic curve diffie-hellman key
exchange
whatever then the server
responds with a random value it sends
over its certificate which for our
purposes we only it will contain a
public rsa key
and a signature from a known trusted
authority on that public rsa key
and then it will choose a cipher suite
which for our purposes it will say okay
i would like to speak diffie-hellman
with you
and it will send over its diffie-hellman
key exchange value and it will sign
that key exchange value with its rsa
public key
then alice says cool we're speaking
diffie-hellman
here's my value g to the b now we have a
full defeat helmet handshake
we derive some
authentication keys and some encryption
keys from using
our diffie-hellman key exchange value
and
our client and server randoms that we
exchanged
and then we exchange max
of the full dialogue here or hopefully
the full dialogue in order to
make sure that we both agree on what
this handshake looks like using our
shared secret that we've derived here
and then alice sends over hey can you
send me in
index.html and the using
symmetric encryption and the website
says here's index.html
ciphers or not the the mac it does not
or no no it does sorry uh yes
this includes the list of ciphers
and the chosen cipher
and it also it's kind of structural it
includes the g to the a and g to the b
yes yes
um i am i am lying to you in in many
places in this slide because this is
like a huge cartoon i mean you can go
read the tls rfc if you want to be
scared for your life
um i think it's a good it's a good thing
for crypto people to do uh but yes
so so this this includes like all of the
important things here
so this is
um okay so what what provides
authentication here we have a sort of
sequence of things
um we trust the signatures from the
certificate authorities because we have
their public keys and we trust their
public keys implicitly
the certificate authorities sign the
server's
diffie-hellman value so this
authenticates the server to us
and then um the
server is sending a mac of the whole
dialogue so
we sort of chain trust that way um and
then the encryption is just given by
the divi helmet values due to the to be
of course there's no authentication of
the
client but the server doesn't really
care who the client is you can do this
in tls but nobody does
so that's kind of like where these
guarantees come from in the actual
protocol
this is much more complicated than the
first slide
um okay so there's some many differences
here between
uh practice and theory uh there's the
negotiation part there's the politics of
what's what cipher suits we include here
i'm going to talk about this in a second
um if you teach a crypto class you
mentioned
elgamal immediately after diffie-hellman
but almost nobody uses alcohol except
for pgp for whatever reason
um there's often group negotiation that
needs to be built in somewhere
there's i talked about the short
exponents a choice that seems fine
but comes with some caveats there's this
long tail distribution of group
parameters most of which are not known
to be vulnerable but
we don't know how to choose groups
better than others is it good to have
everybody use the same groups should
everybody generate distinct groups
i don't know and then there's some
interesting things like if you scan for
ssh
which we did and you look at what primes
people are using
there are only a few thousand primes
used by
um all i don't know 10 15 million
servers
supporting ssh and almost all of them
have almost all of their bits in common
so there's in fact a list of so
ssh unlike
unlike tls actually does have a group
negotiation protocol
but the group negotiation only
negotiates out of a set list of primes
which are basically just starting at a
value and incrementing
next prime for a little while so they
all share almost
all but like the 32 least significant
bits in common
which is really odd i mean i don't see a
vulnerability here
but if somebody wants to think about
this that's something weird
given what i'm going to talk about okay
so
why i'm like out of time all right so
does anybody actually use
512-bit diffie-hellman so in the cartoon
version well okay
so if somebody was dumb enough to
so if a server uses a
512-bit diffie-hellman group here then
we know we can just break this offline
we're fine there are some servers that
do this most of them are not
dumb enough to do this there's some
servers that are still using 256 but
diffie-hellman
because you know 256-bit crypto is
secure uh
okay but does anybody use 512-bit
diffie-hellman um
actually a lot more servers support
512-bit diffie-hellman than you would
like
and the reason goes back to say the 90s
crypto wars
so this is from the itar regulations
back in the battle days when
cryptography was regulated as a munition
of course we are allowed to export
cryptography i am exporting cryptography
right now by giving a talk
um but they're actually cryptography is
still
on the commerce control list of the
united states and you need an export
license to
export cryptography
of any kind of security factorization of
integers in excess of 512 bits
discrete logs of larger than 512 bits
this is still
active uh so you can export
this cryptography that's okay
i don't know it's great logarithms in
any group well yeah i guess it doesn't
say anything yeah so
lettuce is good okay um you should be
careful it might end up on the list
if you succeed it will end up on the
list if it chris excuse yeah
isn't it isn't it true though that that
doesn't actually apply to most countries
or i thought i read about this a little
while ago and
i thought that there was like a list of
countries that
some countries on some known bad list
that you couldn't export
strong crypto to but like most most
countries
you can there are actually in practice
no export controls
in practice there haven't been export
rules for a while
although i am not a lawyer and i don't
know exactly what the regulations are if
you're if you're like a normal
individual human being you're fine but i
know of researchers who get hassled by
the universities over
export licenses like posting something
on the internet is
is exporting to one of these bad
countries so
because universities don't always hire
the most competent lawyers
well that is not the government's fault
well i'm a little bit alarmed by this to
be i mean especially given all the other
crypto war stuff that's going on
posting code or posting papers with the
description of the
there's an algorithm for research yeah
research is accepted
so if you said that it's okay yeah yeah
we haven't had to worry about this
in a while um but the artifact that this
turned out um this this resulted in is
back in the battle days of the 90s
if you wanted to post a version of
netscape online that supported
cryptography
uh it could it was only allowed to speak
uh
well for for people who who were outside
of the united states to download it was
only allowed to speak
these export cipher suites
and many servers i mean modern browsers
don't support these cipher suites they
don't announce hey i'm willing to speak
export
grade cryptography but many servers
never turned off support
for these export grade cipher suites
because what's the harm is a real client
is never going to negotiate such a thing
and we wouldn't want to cause any
problems for people who never upgraded
from netscape from 1996.
so in march 2015 uh
expert cypher suites are supported by
36.7
of these 14 million sites which is
surprisingly large um and there was a
paper uh
intersection with our paper is karthik
bhargavan
which they had several vulnerabilities
but um this included the freak attack
which
used uh fast 512 factorization to
downgrade modern browsers to broken
export grade rsa this attack relied on
multiple things
one of them was a implementation flaw in
almost everybody's tls implementations
where
a man in the middle could just send an
unexpected message to
the server and the server would just not
notice that it was unexpected and
instead negotiate
broken export-grade crypto and if you
figured out what their current key of
the day or week
was and factored in advance in a few
hours on ec2 as one can do
then the the man in the middle can then
just
use the factorization to to forge the
mac of the handshake
using um as if everybody had negotiated
the cipher suites they expected to
and then it will just go through so that
was an implementation flaw
so then um one of the things that we did
in this paper is
extend this idea to diffie-hellman yeah
so that meant that let's say that i'm
trying to
connect by a cls to i don't know to
berkeley
and the men in the middle intercepts it
and now they have a key with me or with
the server
they are able to
they now have your shared secret um so
they have downgraded your connection to
export grade cryptography
so they can compute both of the uh the
encryption and the mac keys and then and
then they can start injecting whatever
they want into the connection
so they they need to do a 500 drill bit
factorization
but actually all of the implementations
only generate a 512-bit key
when they start up and then they use
that key until the next time the server
is rebooted
and so if a server stays online for a
few days or a few weeks as they do
then you have a few days or weeks in
order to factor this key
so then you could say well what happens
with diffie-hellman
well back you know if you think that
512-bit diffie-hellman has the same
amount of security as a 512-bit rsa key
exchange
unlike uh generating ephemeral rsa
ephemeral export rsa keys servers
actually do generate a new
export ephemeral export diffie-hellman
exchange every time they get a
connection so you would have to break
the discrete log
in real time and if it cost as much as a
500 bit factorization for each of these
then such a downgrade attack would not
be possible
but because we can
do a pre-computation for a prime and
then do the online computation for
uh an actual target much much faster
that means that uh
that a downgrade attack of this form
actually is possible
i mean that b minus one is smooth no
that's that's in general for 512 bit
so that's using the number field save
implementation numbers that i
i gave with a 90 second ish
online cost to compute an individual
discrete log if you know the prime
in advance how critical is it to switch
this
red stuff from the helm and explore to
dp helm on exchange
so um so this is a somewhat confusing
diagram
of the downgrade attack so um so the
client says
i'm a modern client i speak normal
diffie-hellman key exchange
i definitely don't speak diffie-hellman
export the man in the middle replaces
all of the perfectly good cipher suites
that the client is willing to speak
with i only speak diffie-hellman export
hello i'm
mosaic from the 90s and the server says
okay fine i speak diffie-hellman export
here's my
key exchange values and here's a
signature of
my key exchange which includes all the
parameters
but not the diffie-hellman export and so
the
the man in the middle passes this
through and and the client
just thinks that the server speaks
normal diffie-hellman
but with a 512-bit group it can't tell
the difference between diffie-hellman
downgraded diffie-hellman export and
davey hellman
normal diffie-hellman with a 512-bit
group it means that you just use a short
exponent
downgraded beans uses a 512-bit p
prime so then why can't i tell i can see
that the
prime is short but some people use
normal diffie-hellman with a 512-bit
prime
so if that's effective yeah well yeah
um except that this this server might
say i'm going to be safe i'm going to
use a 2048-bit prime
but i'm going to keep i'm going to keep
export on because nobody normal would
negotiate this with me
and i want to make sure i can get all
the customers i have so
the effect of this downgrade attack is
to keep the client from
it's to cause a client who's connecting
to a server that they would normally
have perfectly
good security with um to downgrade it to
bad security if the server is willing to
negotiate broken crypto with people who
only speak broken crypto
are the macs no longer part of the
picture here the macs are the
so so the macs are part of the picture
so there's a signature we can't forge
the signature because this is with the
full size rsa key
so the rest of the key exchange goes
through now
in order for the man in the middle to
convince the client that everything has
gone okay
it needs to compute this mac and in
order to compute this mac it needs to
figure out what the mac key was and in
order to figure out what the mac he is
it needs to compute the the discrete log
of the
downgraded diffie-hellman key exchange
since your export control mode is in the
mac key only 40 bits anyway
it's like i'm not sure
40 56 i don't know
uh we need to know that it's correct
yeah so we need to we need to compute
the correct one so if we just compute
the discrete log then we immediately
know what the correct one is just and
just send it
students since you're saying the client
is trying to use secure stuff but secure
stuff is only 512 bits
so i'm just not understanding the
difference between this dhe and dhe
export if both of them are 512.
so um so normally if the man in the
middle wasn't here and the client says i
want to speak deiche
the server would say here's some 2048
bit parameters for you
so they lie about param so the client
doesn't notice that the
prime is really short or something yeah
so
until our paper the cl the clients would
never alert on
on 512-bit keys and this should be clear
to the client
how often do you check how often do you
check what parameters you were being
sent
well but um there were so many sites out
there that were still speaking
512-bit primes that the the server
the the browser implementations didn't
want to cut it off
is this attack at least adding this
prime with some leading zeros so you
don't even know that you should
show the screen you just send a primer
so
until our paper
so at some point i think most browsers
except a couple had had cut off primes
less than 512 bits but there was sort of
this popular
conception that 500 i mean doing online
512-bit discrete log
was as hard as doing a factorization
every time
so it's not you know nobody's going to
who's going to do that so this is
clearly not a vulnerability
so if we just signed instead of what we
do sign now which includes uh
g to the a or g to the b if we also
signed
uh the list of ciphers then we'd be done
right
yeah so yeah so so this is this is a
flaw in the protocol
that the server is not signing its
choice of
cipher suite and also a typical key
theoretical key agreement when
we don't do a mac we use a signature at
the end which also deploys
yeah those are more expensive just to
make sure i understand correctly when
the server says
it thinks that this is a computation
over it interprets this as
numbers over 512 big prime but the
client thinks of
g to the g to the a as uh
something over 2000. they both agree on
the choice of prime
so the server thinks oh this client only
speaks this
um broken crypto so i'm going to send it
a 512 bit prime
and i'm going to send it g to the a-mod
that 512-bit prime so the client and the
server both agree on what their prime
and their generator and everything are
there are other cross-pro there are
other sort of cross-protocol attacks
where
the client and the server like the man
in the middle convinces the client to
send
uh one kind of key and and the client
and the client interprets it as the
wrong kind of key there's some there's
some cute attacks of that form also but
this is not that this is
everybody agrees that they're speaking
512-bit discrete
or diffie-hellman does they play in
checkbook
clients don't do anything so you could
send a smooth number even if it's longer
you cannot get a signature right so so
you need to force a certificate from the
server and that will unfortunately
include the right prime and the right uh
we're not forging anything we're so
we're assuming the signature is good
will not work because i mean the most
trivial target is for men in the middle
just to send like a five bit primers and
you're saying nobody checks everything
but you're saying they wouldn't be
it won't pass because of the signals
yeah we can't we can't we can't do that
because
the the server is is signing yeah
so um when the when they exchange
max of the protocol transcript before
the actual
encryption does that does the mac also
include the cipher suite
uh yes which is why the man in the
middle needs to forge it
then the man in the middle needs to
compute discrete blog
online while the while the
client the server communicating yes so
even if it only takes 10 seconds isn't
there like a timeout
that would take place or so there's a
there's a list of things that you can do
in practice
i deleted that slide because i was told
to like focus on the math here um so
there's
uh you might say okay yeah 10 seconds is
like way longer than a normal person is
willing to wait
so things that you could imagine
happening there are all sorts of little
ad beacons
that get transferred um so like you
wouldn't notice if you loaded
new york times and then there was a tiny
little ad beacon that took 10 seconds or
90 seconds to load while you were
looking at the page
but in the man in the middle attacker
could then insert some malicious thing
instead of that ad beacon onto your onto
your page and and you would trust it
because it was https
um another example is uh if you were
doing
um uh https over some offline client
like you just had a
web script that was downloading things
then the script is not going to notice
if it takes
an extra 10 seconds to connect to a page
probably then there are a few other you
can send like
keep a live messages that will that will
delay
the finished message timeout
until the attacker has time to complete
the discrete log
so given given like a choice of an
ephemeral
exponent for divi hellman this only
needs to be done
does this need to be done per connection
or per new choice of the femoral
exponent
or a new choice of ephemeral exponent
like if a web server is up for a week
and it's using the same ephemeral
exponent for the entire time
then it just has to do this once and
then every
every client is is problem-based yes
will the server actually use the same
family exponent uh
i mean why not choose new one uh for
exponent grade
crypto um the servers were using a new
new exponent every time they were
connected to for non-export-grade
diffie-hellman ephemeral means
um i generate one when i boot up
and then i use that same one forever
until
the next time i'm rebooted that is still
an
option that's still happening that is
that is the way that uh
many servers operate uh do you think
apache does this
but are there other servers that are
using export great crypto and
also not generating a new exponent for
not that we saw i think or maybe only a
tiny handful
so the vast majority of these guys were
generating a new
uh ephemeral exponent for every
connection for export
but not for the full-sized iffy helmet
so uh right okay so carrying out the
attack
um we need to do pre-computation for the
primes so you can ask how many
how many pre-computations do we need to
do to attack everybody on the internet
um
the most common prime is used by 82
percent of the servers that
uh supported export grade crypto so you
get a lot of bang out of your
uh one week of computation there the
next most common prime is 10
and then there's kind of a long tail of
distributions again
um i had this before one week on on
youtube
2000 to 3000 cores the individual
descent times it actually has this sort
of nice
s curve it's it's kind of a random
process how long it takes
i'm embarrassed by this number because
it should be less than a minute but the
code
is not very well threaded so this number
is larger than it should be
um maybe we'll improve it
uh okay so i'm totally out of time but
i'm going to tell you about the
politically more interesting part of
this paper
uh i guess if you want to leave you
should leave but um
okay so we've established that many
hosts use the same group parameters and
there's this possibility of a
precomputation attack
the with much faster online individual
uh discrete logs if um
if everybody's using the same parameters
so what does this say about
passive attacks on 768 or 10 24-bit
diffie-hellman which are very commonly
in practice
so here are some numbers for
cost estimates of discrete log
we got these in a few different ways so
the current factoring record is 768 bit
rsa
this is from late 2009 published in 2010
so here's some sieving ranges and
large prime bounds and this is slightly
adjusted from the numbers in their paper
so they did a lot more sieving than they
needed to in order to make the linear
algebra easier
we backed off a little bit from that so
this is sort of
estimated what it would cost using
modern hardware
normal computer cpus to do 768-bit
factorization
if somebody were to repeat that result
now
to modify this number for diffie-hellman
as i said before we
have this problem that the linear
algebra is way more expensive so we want
to do more work in the sieving phase in
order to
reduce our workload in the linear
algebra phase so
there's kind of a limit to how far you
can push this
so this number is saying okay we do 10
times as much sieving
here and we decrease the size of our
matrix
somewhat and still the linear algebra is
like
way more expensive but we did some
experiments and the descent
is about two chord days so this is i
mean if you paralyze this then this is
not so bad at all um then
the sort of more interesting question is
10 24 bits
it's been sort of a sport i guess for
cryptographers to say
what how expensive is 1024-bit rsa for
the past couple of decades right
um so here's some extrapolated
parameters sort of
from here if you scale things up
appropriately
this is about how expensive we expect
1024-bit rsa to be
and correspondingly if we expect the
same
ish approximate benefit from
over-sieving and
decreasing the size of the matrix
here's about what it would cost so this
is a rather large number
this is not such a large number this is
rather large um
and the descent is actually not that bad
so this number i mean this was the
the inria people um some experiments
with the early abort elliptic curve
method this was
um published by dan bernstein and tanya
longa who were talking about
doing a batch number field sieve so this
seems to be the best way to do the
descent so with some experiments we did
not run it all the way through but with
some experiments
we guessed that the descent will take
about 30 days
so this is about what you expect
sort of 10 24-bit rsa and diffie-hellman
to look like
now just to be clear these are four days
these are core days yes so all of these
things can be parallelized
this can be paralyzed perfectly this is
less so
this is pretty well parallel
so
what does this look like if you have the
resources of a government
the best current design for factoring
that we
found is an asic living design um
this is this paper is almost 10 years
old at this point so moving to sort of
modern designs
um the number is quite low at actually
eight million dollars to sieve a 1024
bit discrete log
with the 10 times over sieving that we
estimate
in hardware but there's a problem with
this the linear algebra step
which is if you take the largest
supercomputer purchased by the nsa which
has
30 300 000 cores the linear algebra step
would take 117 years
so this is clearly not quite feasible
but it is within a constant factor
feasible which is
what should uh worry everybody so if you
either assume that there are some smart
people out there who have gotten
a hundred time improvement or
if you can expect say 80 times speed up
for doing linear algebra
in hardware special purpose hardware
this would cost hundreds of millions of
dollars but
this is not out of range it is so close
to in range that
this should clearly be retired
that is where it gets more exciting okay
so
i don't know how many of you read this
article there's an article in 2012 by
james banford
talking about large breakthroughs that
the nsa made this
this is priest noted by the way the nsa
made an enormous breakthrough several
years ago in its ability to crypt
analyze or break unfathomably complex
encryption systems
employed not only by governments around
the world but but also many average
computer users in the us
um they were thinking that this
computing breakthrough was going to give
them the ability to crack current public
encryption
and in the rest of this article i've cut
this out he sort of
alludes to he thinks it's aes
but i don't know about you i read this
and i said this doesn't sound like aes
this sounds like i don't know 10 24 but
rsa maybe
that was that was my speculation i think
the next slide
if you have a clearance over your eyes
so this is from the snowden leaks a
brief quote from the
2013 nsa black budget
we are investing in groundbreaking crypt
analytic capabilities to defeat
adversarial cryptography and exploit
internet traffic
so they're making it very clear that
they are doing something online
to the internet right now
um all right keep averting your eyes if
you have a clearance um so this
is from one of the snowden leaks this is
a slide about decryption of vpn traffic
so this is sort of out of context can we
decrypt the vpn traffic
if the answer is no then explain how to
turn it into a yes if the answer is yes
then
this is my favorite slide from the
leagues ever
have happy i mean i feel this way when i
decrypt things too um
so um but this gives some information i
mean most of the snowden lakes there
hasn't really been a lot about
cryptography
to be honest like there's not much like
technical things in there
we find out about like kind of what the
capabilities are there's some like
numbers but really the only sort of
cryptographically interesting thing in
there has been
what was extrapolated to become the dual
acdrbg
back uh backdoor other than that like
you know what has been in there
but this this is this slide is
interesting because it
makes it clear that they're able to
decrypt
vpns and in particular um
well okay i can esp um
on a large scale and in the same slide
deck they talk sort of in the same
breath about tls and about ssh
and when this was published many people
saw this and they said well okay
um you need the uh esp
exchange i don't know you need um you
need the pre-shared key
they're using pre-shared keys i guess
they're just stealing keys out of
sysadmins emails
and and whatnot so i don't know that's
how they work
but okay classified stuff is over
if you look at the
ike key exchange this is one way that
vpn traffic can be negotiated this is a
total cartoon but the way that
it looks like is so if a client wants to
negotiate
with a server alice sends over a list of
pre-chosen groups there's a list of
about 10 of these
many of them are these oakley oakley
groups that were generated in the 90s
768 1024 bits um there's a 1024-bit dsa
group
uh and then there's a couple possible
elliptic curve groups but there's a very
short list of groups
of about 10. so alice supports some
number of these groups
bob bob chooses one of these groups or
says hey i don't support any of these
groups try again
and then does it and then they do a
diffie-hellman key exchange and then
when they're actually doing the
in order to transition to encrypted
traffic they
both have a pre-shared key and then they
apply a prf to the negotiated
diffie-hellman secret and the pre-shared
key and they derive their
shared secret and then they they move to
uh symmetric encryption
so this is kind of what it looks like so
if
the nsa as they claim is breaking vpn
traffic on a large scale
they either need to have some kind of
vulnerability in
the symmetric traffic or something
that's sent here
or they need to be
both collecting the pre-shared key and
somehow breaking this
this diffie-hellman key exchange so
either there's a symmetric break
there's some kind of protocol flaw
that's offline or there's a
or they're breaking the diffie-hellman
key exchange
and so if you sort of
look at the precomputation numbers it's
close enough that
breaking the 1024
the 768 bit and the 10 24 bit groups
that everybody is using that is
consistent
with if you've done that pre-computation
then that is consistent with being able
to break
the discrete log passively
um at will for not that much effort
and then being able to decrypt this
traffic consistent with
um if you look at so oh wait sorry
highlight if you have a clearance close
your eyes again
um so this is a picture of the
infrastructure the crypt analytic
infrastructure that is used to decrypt
the vpn traffic so they take the key
exchange messages
they feed them into this specialized
infrastructure that they have they send
the key exchange messages
through a series of well attack
orchestrator
and then they eventually get to high
performance computing resources
and this is a database of the of known
pre-shared keys
if the pre-shared key is known and
whatever this high
performance computing resources come
back with a success
then they are able to send back um
the decryption keys and then the
decrypted data goes into some databases
this is what their infrastructure for
decrypting this stuff looks like
so the sort of big picture is
they take this handshake they send it to
some big computers
they come back with the symmetric shared
secret and they decrypt everything
so if we hypothesize that it is possible
to break a single uh 10-24-bit prime to
do one pre-computation that would take a
few hundred million dollars and one year
um this would allow breaking
66 percent of
traffic to 66 percent of all of the
hosts on the internet
that speak uh vpn traffic
and actually only doing the
precomputation for a single 1024
prime so for ssh and um ike
these are the same prime so if you've if
you've done that pre-computation for
um this 1024-bit prime then
you get 25 percent of ssh of
well you get traffic to 25 of ssh hosts
for free
um this is a different prime but if you
throw in having done that precomputation
for one more prime
then you get say uh 37
of all https traffic
these are numbers from internet wide
scans of
how much traffic you could break if you
could break all 512-bit primes
all 768-bit primes um 1
10 24 or 10 10 24-bit primes this is
what
uh if this is assuming passive
collection so this is what the servers
want to negotiate with the most commonly
used clients out there my understanding
your percentages so those are relative
percentages of
uh percentage of 66 percent percentage
percentage
of vpn traffic give an estimate as to
how much vpn traffic there is
we're not the nsa it would be
wiretapping to uh
get that number maybe maybe some isps
have it
um but yeah i don't know i mean there's
a lot of corporate networks out there
and looking at sort of the
intelligence applications i mean they're
clearly interested in the traffic that's
going over these corporate networks
so um it may be that sort of as
cryptographers and as security people by
focusing on
https as like the application of
cryptanalysis all the time
we've missed the really big
important target here which people
weren't really paying attention to which
is this protocol
that has baked in a set of 10 pre-fixed
groups
and where most of the clients prefer to
speak using a single 10-24-bit
prime so
this is my last slide i'm totally over
time so some practical mitigations um
this is sort of an order of preference i
think
um what do you do about this well move
to elliptic curve crypto we don't have
the same kind of precomputation attacks
for elliptic curves as we do for
discrete log
um you know you could say and you know
okay um if elliptic curve crypto isn't
an option
um then switch sorry that should be 2048
bit primes
um move two larger than 2048 bit primes
although i guess 2018 bit primes are
also okay
and if 2048-bit primes aren't an option
then
reusing the same 10-24-bit primes is
probably a bad idea
especially the one that people have been
using for decades um and major browsers
have been rolling out fixes
i think apple just rolled out one this
week um
uh refusing to accept 512 bid groups and
they will be sun setting to 768 and 10
24 bit soon
so um i think for sort of a more
theoretical audience if you're thinking
about
what will lattice-based crypto look like
in a couple of decades when you've won
and it has become one of the most
commonly u
used and deployed crypto systems out
there um
knowing what we know now about sort of
the development of cryptographic
parameters through the 80s and 90s
how would you standardize your
constructions
so that they can be secure for as long
as possible do you negotiate parameters
or do you
like just say these are the one set of
solid good parameters nobody gets to
change them ever
how do you protect against
implementation mistakes because clearly
the implementer needs to be considered
as an adversary in
our model um and also how do you defend
against politics
so if how do you make sure that
some malicious person on your
standardization committee didn't
actually
manage to slip in a secret set of
backdoor parameters
against your will so um
our paper is online at weekdh.org
there's
instructions for sysadmins to change the
baked in primes and the parameters in
many different kinds of software and
there's some videos so you can
watch us man in the middle in
connections too lots of things so
thank you
so i have a question about the like the
export the export down very fast um so
in the attack it seems like it's a
fairly crucial step that the man in the
middle is able to
make the client think that it's
speaking of dhe instead of phd export
do you have a sense of is that necessary
or because i know it's like the
so the client sends a list of cypher
suites that will look sad
right and then if it gets back
just dhe export is it the future of the
protocol that if
dhe exports wasn't in that original list
of ports yeah
oh okay so that's why you need the
client to think that it's doing php
yeah yeah if the server sends back like
hey i'm going to speak this cipher suite
that you totally didn't send me
then the client will say this is wrong
tls breaks over the last few years there
was
quite a few maybe almost 10 years ago
there was this whole discussion about
mqv and kind of sun setting and qpm
getting
something that will provide forward
secrecy for key exchange so then there
was
um the the government standard whatever
it was 800-56
or something like that and and ibm
provided a lot of
comments on that and and microsoft
provided a lot of comments
and my understanding was that most of
the comments were
ignored they had to do with things like
using hmqv
instead of mqb or microsoft had
proposals like naxos
or other things after that and those
would all essentially replace the usual
you know dippy helmet with
a version that had some forward secrecy
so i i would think that that would be
another thing you could add to your list
of practical medications
i also wonder if you know if anything
has been adopted in that direction
i don't know if anything for tls i mean
maybe there's cypher suites but i
haven't seen them
been negotiated by any clients that i
use
no i don't think they were standardized
but
i'm not sure what other protocols might
be using those things i haven't been
paying attention to the
elliptic curve politics very much oh
it's not elliptic oh it's
that provides oh secrecy right instead
of just having
the usual uh static and ephemeral of
exponents
you also do something like a hash of
that stack up the static and the
envelope
or that what
okay um yeah i mean
i guess you could just say that
everybody should all the servers should
use
actually ephemeral per connection
exponents
which would seem to also sort of uh
at least make some of these things
better but
some do and some don't
okay so there's a movie starting soon so
let's turn
you